peralta hey don't you one minute me i
will break that finger off hang up that
phone i'm talking to my credit card
company i tried to get an online
subscription to the new yorker and they
declined me
apparently based on my previous
purchases they assumed it was fraud
it's crazy i'm fancy one time i had
coffee flavored ice cream
shut up hang up now
if you're not desperate the first two
paragraphs of the article are on the
free site
you have one minute to look it up and
then if i catch you on that phone again
oh my but don't worry i'm due for an
upgrade and my babies are on a cloud
he is so strong you ready serge
i was born ready and then i was not born
ready for a while but now i'm back to
being born ready yes
the ebony falcon soars again the ebony
falcon
his feathers are muscles let's talk
strategy later tonight at my house
my wife's working late i'm on daddy duty
but you're ready for this right
absolutely i just need to put my
precious babies to bed with a story
the ebony falcon needs to read go dog go
yeah he does terry jeffords is back
chest bump me you don't want to do this
man no i really do
it hurts you every time no i know but
i'm fired up the adrenaline is gonna
carry me through here we go
hello terry i just thought i'd stop by
and let you know that i'm on my way to
the bank
that's right i'm gonna pay you back
because
i know your secret what are you talking
about i don't have a secret
oh really fact the first after years of
not caring about my debt you weirdly
want me to pay you back now
that implies to me that there is a
sudden unexpected expense
or i got sick of waiting for you to do
the right thing not plausible
you have endless patience for my
shenanigans fact the second
you've had dentist appointments twice in
the past two weeks
no one goes to the dentist that much i
haven't been in seven years
you should go to the dentist jake
probably my teeth hurt all the time
fact the third i'm really liking this
fact the thing i'm gonna stick with it
fact the fourth i found this on your
desk it's a list of names
nathaniel jeffords alexa jeffords those
are my cousin's names
lies there's but one conclusion you
terry jeffords are pregnant the names
are baby names the dentist
an obstetrician and the money is for
baby things
like diapers
what are you talking about man that is
crazy
damn it does anybody else know no just
you and your wife
and crash that's what i think you should
name the baby works for a boy or a girl
listen up jake we just found out sharon
is pregnant and it's way too early to
tell anyone
this is a secret do you understand me
yeah do you do you understand me oh this
got physical very quickly
this is adult stuff jake be serious look
i promise i won't tell anyone all right
my lips are sealed
good do i even weigh anything to you no
it's like holding a couple of grapes you
better look cute in this picture no
one's gonna want you
do something with your damn paws whoa
whoa sarge relax
look i think you might be overreacting a
little to this prank and i should know
you probably won't believe this but i
was bullied in high school
for being too handsome i don't believe
you you're right it was for setting my
crotch on fire in shop class hurt like
the
dickens point is hater's gone hate shake
it off taylor swift always right
the reason bullies get to me is because
i live with one my dad
he was a cruel man who didn't like his
life and he took it out on me okay
okay now we're getting somewhere but if
you're having dad problems
that's my jam son real weird take on my
crappy father you know how i turned the
corner with my dad
i stood up to him and that's what you
need to do with your dad no he died in
1988.
okay well that probably won't work then
but it doesn't mean you can't go over to
the 6'5 and stand up to those bullies oh
just make fun of me more what are you
talking about terry you are a human
mountain
you have more muscles in your ears than
i have in my entire body never skip ear
day jake you can crush metal with your
bare hands
you can lift a city bus you can make
your boobies do that bouncy thing
they're called pecks same thing
now get on over the 6'5 and make those
big jerks take back that tiny kitten
yeah all right i'm doing it
we've busted murderers we've taken down
cartels
but today we face the worst new york has
to offer
the fire department
fire marshall boom we meet again
detective peralta
your flies down it made you look i
didn't look and i'm wearing shorts there
is no fly that's not what your mom said
you make no sense
and now i'm inside your head prepare to
die
[Applause]
[Applause]
you don't have to dance every time true
but i choose the dad every time
[Applause]
you have one play you give the ball to
jeffords and he runs it in i
i'd like to see you score one good
because you're about to see it
you're about to see it straight to hell
to say this but you two are acting like
bad dads and i should know one time my
father forgot to pick me up from school
cause he was having sex with my best
friend's mom
my god that's terrible yeah i mean i was
15. i just walked the mall and watched
empire records by myself but the point
is you're both acting ridiculous
no this is on you jake you need to make
a choice that's not fair you both want
to go and i don't want to hurt either of
you
but maybe i don't have to i can let fate
hurt you
we'll flip a coin terry call it in the
air heads or tails
neither oh my god did you just fold my
quarter in half
fate's a [ __ ] you make the choice
just so you know i would never bend your
money yeah cause you can't correct i
cannot no one can how did he do that
any news sergeant uh last i heard
they've located one shooter but they
can't get to him oh i'm sorry
i didn't realize you were on the phone
oh just don't hold what's up i just
wanted to check in to see if you were
all right i couldn't help but notice
that you've flattened your mouse
sorry i get crushy when i'm nervous
hey terry you getting my email
about how i was coming down here no i
haven't checked my phone
ah no need i just wanted to make sure
you're here you know you know how i like
to have a weight mate
really i have never seen you in the gym
what
i basically live here i'm a regular gym
dandy
besides i got to get into shape for all
the godfathering i'm going to do i mean
how am i going to throw our baby up into
the air with these noodle arms
good point so take me through your
workout man rip me up you know let's rip
it out time to rip it down
those aren't gym terms and i don't think
you can handle my workout oh wow
sounds like a challenge to me come on
give it in
i gotcha ready yep oh my gosh
is it cool if i just stare at your
croissants for a little while sarge
you need to stop this diet amy and i
folded you won
it's not a competition we were on the
same team until you deserted me for team
eating food
was that a good burn i'm too hungry to
tell it was a great burn sir
now please eat you look weak i'm fine i
am stronger than ever
watch this
serge what are you doing
see i'm fine
what is happening just to tell me gurgle
dad messed up my sister
oh no
[Music]
go back inside are you talking to us or
the fart
damn it boyle you left the fridge open
the door couldn't shut because of your
empty pizza box
pizza please this is a butternut squash
and truffle butter flatbread
everything's spoiled my lunch is ruined
my chicken my potatoes
my pasta my meatballs pam
my yogurt a lot of yogurt i love yogurt
so this is your lunch for like the month
i need to eat 10 000 calories a day to
maintain muscle mass
my wife made me all of this before she
left town with the kids that was
everything in my fridge
scully hey serge i know you got a secret
stash of food hidden somewhere oh no
where is it no i don't is it in your
pocket oh come on
i'm going to shake it out of your
pockets turn around sorry
go live scully oh this is fun
release you're sweet i was overweight
and lonely
and i wrote dc paula for advice and he
sent me this
i hope it's not a severed head
the sky fire cycle sand into glass the
reckoning of
collar man that is a long book is the
rest of it just more of the title it's
the book that started it all
okay and listen to the inscription he
wrote terry
you do have friends i'd like you have me
never forget that in this life
we write our own stories
paulo and that's what happened
little terry wrote his own story yeah a
little terry got buffa
little terry got emotionally healthy
yeah and drank
you know what he didn't get jacked
way to go little jerry big backs coming
through
you